You had a bunch of fights in UFC, by the way, make sure that I,
I don't forget to tell the kill Jocko story. I gotta tell that story later,
but we'll just tell it right now. Well, I'll say, but, but um, okay.
So I was not, I mean there wasn't pride at the time.
Jocko went to Afghans. We were somewhere, I think it was,
I think it was my first deployment to Iraq for a couple months and then it was
maybe I was just doing a walk maybe if I'm not sure, but you were gone and um,
you come back and my mom had this, uh, medication.
I had acne and o t this was, it was some kind of antibiotic helped it,
but I didn't know it made me really weak and uh, took my endurance away.
This is actually true. This is not an excuse that they [inaudible].
So Jocko comes back and I'm not really feeling a good song cause I was trained.
I'm like, okay, and Jagoda kicks my ass. And junk was like, literally,
he's angry. He's like, you lazy more than we, I'm in the desert.
I'm doing this and you're, you're sitting on your ass,
you understand you'll do nothing and I kicked your ass. And W and I'm like, Eh,
I'm just like, I was like, I'm like ashamed, shaming myself. Cause,
cause then you go away for like a month or somewhere you're gone. And I'm like,
and I, but that medication, we were at 10 days and I stopped him.
I feel strong again. I'm like, oh, I understand now. So I'm training. I'm like,
mother [inaudible] comes back. I can't wait for this. I made a CD
kill Jocko and it was, I like corn in Metallica, so I'll use like,
it's a job came in, I'm like, Hey Jocko. And I put this money in and we train.
And that was my day, I guess. I think I was like talking Shit Dude,
like you, my feelings were hurt, you're gonna talk to me.
And here's what sucks for me is so if, if both of us are on point, I'm get,
I'm catching the beat down. If so, if both of us are bringing our a game on,
catching the beat down,
if Dean's bringing his a game and I'm bringing my week game,
I'm catching a beat down.
If I'm bringing my full a game and beans having a horrible day,
I do like barely. Okay.
So it's like I'll have your days whether you have good days,
they really good days that I have are, are very, I have to, I have to earn them.
I'll put it through that way I have to earn them.
And then so you do UFC,
you do decent. UFCU has some tough fights, good fights. Three,
four ranked in my division. My,
my only two losses by decision was named mark and you should know,
call me and they both after that fight fire and as the silver.
So I was two times right there. Fight for the belt. I was top five, top four.
No, I don't care. Tops. What I fought to fight and Sylvan,
I lost both those matches, but the four I won. And uh,
my first fight was Elisa Sakara who was from Italy's really tough fighter fat.
Probably the fastest hands. And actually I figured this out later.
I was the underdog, but they were actually trying to feed me to him.
He was gonna fight chocolate. Allow her, you are stepping stone.
Well supposedly you're supposed to demand this screwed up.
They were already planning like using a fight.
Chocolate l cause he has probably f he has faster hands.
Probably Chuck has a really good Chen, better wrestling,
but Sakara faster hands, better boxing. So yeah. Oh, have them fight after.
That's what I heard. But um,
that day I got in the same triangle I got showed you a Karin and uh,
but he taught, uh, showed your here, went to sleep.
So both my debuts won't one by the same move and up against a tough guys.
So then I find, uh, another Japanese opponent.
I fight a Bulgarian Olympic wrestler. I fought Nate Mar. Quote,
you should have called me and I fought Jeremy Horn. So six fights in USC.
So my career has been focused on Jujitsu more No-gi is because when you do MMA
you don't, you don't have a g or ki-moon one. So it kind of wasting your time.
If you're training in that aspect and you don't have a g on your candidate,
how to grab the belt, how to do this, you kind of wasting your time. So yeah,
I've distributed my time between mixed martial arts and grappling.